hi I'm Erik Bosse and Pixar's
Incredibles 2 is a new full trailer with
lots of interesting clues hinting at the
movie's plot some subtle Pixar Easter
eggs and a creepy - villain to teach us
the dangers of staring at screens for
too long not this screen though keep
keep watching please I need attention
and what better way to keep your
attention than to go through this
trailer frame by frame to point out
everything you missed
and as always spoiler warning in case
any of my predictions into being too
accurate let's get started
did you wash your hands with soap did
you dry them I did okay the trailer
opens with the Parr family at dinner and
right away notice Dash's shirt also
Hellen shirt violets shirt and headband
these are these same exact outfits that
they were wearing on the day of Dash's
track race at the end of the first movie
which of course was interrupted by the
arrival of the Underminer
so this movie is picking up right in the
middle of that whole timeline dealing
with the immediate aftermath also notice
this room there's a bed right next to
the dining table yeah this appears to be
some kind of cramped hotel room or
studio apartment probably wherever the
parts had to stay and after their house
was destroyed and then the Chinese
takeout carton includes a Pixar Easter
Egg reference to several past Pixar
movies including A Bug's Life Toy Story
Monsters Inc ratatouille and the family
dinner scene and inside out which
actually yeah it was a very similar
scenario do what the pars are going
through right here who left a good start
with all these missiles so let's keep
going so are we going to talk about it
what the elephant in the room what
elephant
mom's new job okay here violet brings up
the new elephant in the room ver
Incredibles to Helens new gig which we
get a glimpse of here Helen has returned
to her old classic Elastigirl costume
jumping after a helicopter and if you
look closely the background you can see
this neon sign of a cowboy hat now this
is a Pixar movie so this could be
Woody's hat right let's just call it
Woody's hat also another sign of the
background says new urban
savings-and-loan new urban is the name
of a new setting in this movie and
according to a Lego set that was
released for this movie yes toys are
apparently a news source that we use for
these videos the pilot of this
helicopter could be the screen slavered
new villain shows up later in Australia
I'll talk more about this guy when we
get there so let's move on it's time to
make some wrong things right help me
bring supers back into the sunlight
need to change people's perceptions
about superheroes and Elastigirl is our
best play better than me okay in this
section we move on to dev tech
headquarters and its leader Winston
Dever voiced by Bob Odenkirk his pitch
to bring back superheroes back into the
sunlight definitely gives off that shady
businessman vibe of Odin Kirk's
character Saul Goodman and Breaking Bad
a better call Saul she doesn't show up
in this trailer but Winston's sister is
Evelyn Dever she's being voiced by
Catherine Keener and it doesn't take a
genius to spot the Tom Riddle style
wordplay in the character name Eve went
eat her oh my god all this time or more
likely evil endeavour so I think we can
expect the Devers siblings to be behind
the villainy of this movie but more on
that later
we see some shots of the Incredibles and
Frozone in action sweeping the city from
that under minor attack but then look at
the screen behind Winston
it looks like the family gets arrested
after those efforts thus Winston's pitch
to restore their public trust with
Elastigirl not mr. incredible as the
poster hero of that new campaign little
detail I liked here notice how the new
comic book panel style images of the
three of them are depictions of past
battles Frozone glided on an ice path
while fighting the Omnitrix in the car
like when he threw the car at syndromes
jet and Elastigirl fighting an armed
robber on a rooftop like when she
knocked out the armed thief in the
opening scene let's move on to the next
clip watch the kids no trial
not the way you're supposed to do it dad
they want us to do it I don't know that
way why would they change math math okay
in this clip the family arrives at their
fancy new dev tech bot home and if you
look closely you can see the Frank Lloyd
Wright style waterfall Elastigirl drives
a motorcycle out from behind that and we
get a look at what Bob's life is like
now as the stay-at-home dad helping -
with this new math homework new math is
a term for a scrapped progressive
approach to math education in the 50s
but Bob's old frustration here is
probably very relatable to parents
trying to make sense of their kids
Common Core math standards now looking
at the equation on the textbook there to
me it looks like the basic algebraic
step said I learned in middle school I
don't know maybe they changed it since
then solve for x by balancing the sides
of the equation and I have a TD so x
equals so look at the shapes speaking of
distractions check out the TV behind -
the screen is flickering in the spiral
pattern this looks kind of like screen
savers hypnotics signal interference
that we see later in the trailer maybe -
his big dumb head blocking the screen is
the only reason the signal isn't
hypnotizing Bob here hmm let me know
what you think but let's move on hey
honey catch everything is great
[Music]
he's an excellent healthy next during
bob's phone call with helen check out
the intercom on the wall the dev tech
name and logo appear on that now it's
not surprising that dev tech money paid
for this whole house but the fact that
they actually put in the microphone
devices is a little unsettling Winston
and Evelyn could be listening in on all
their conversations and yeah Bob is way
in over his head with the kids evidenced
by this teenage angst he freaked out by
violet and another little detail I liked
here - has a huge stack of waffles just
like that big plate of egg rolls in the
first clip - loves loading up on carbs
this is a detail pulled from another
famous speedster the flash whom - is
definitely inspired by the flash has to
consume a ton of food since yeah he
burns through so much energy from
running so fast let's move on to the
next clip is freaky you know it's crazy
right to help my family I gotta leave it
to fix the law I gotta break it dukhat -
boy kids can have that choice
Thank You young men here Bob struggles
continue as baby Jack Jack teleports
around the house I love this shot of the
sleep-deprived Bob almost snoozing with
his eyes open as Jack Jack dolls on the
cookie meanwhile Helen lives the
superhero life Bob got to live in the
first movie after some shots of her in
the under minor battle there's another
sequence of her chasing this runaway
train you look closely and slow it down
as she crashes through the building she
uses her body's elasticity to absorb the
shock of the landing very cool let's
move on
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robin
okay this section contains one of the
most interesting shots of this trailer
with - running with Jack Jack through a
series of portals in their new home this
could be connected to Jack Jack's
teleportation powers or it's also
possible that this could be the work
avoid a new character who's gonna be in
this movie Boyd is a one of these super
fan of Elastigirl kind of like what
buddy slash syndrome was - mr.
incredible her powers that she can
create voids that allow objects to
appear and disappear whatever the source
of these portals are they operate very
similarly to the portal game series
where you can look through the portal to
see yourself entering it from the other
angle also as portal players know you
can line up portals to build up speed in
momentum maybe - is doing that here
though he's already a speedster I don't
know why he would need to do that
there's also a quick shot of violet
using a force field to protect the
family kind of looks like they could be
inside the machinery of the under miners
drill as it explodes around them and
then briefly you could see - violet and
Jack Jack behind the wheel of this car
but look at the shot closely the car has
what looks like a big chunk of ice on
the hood and as it takes off pieces of
ice burst off of it perhaps Frozone
froze this car to keep the kids from
taking it out on a joyride didn't really
work next violet shows off a new
interesting form of her powers
generating these laser discs and
flinging them to sever a piece of
falling debris to save some people
really if everyone of the family violet
appears to have the most interesting
dimensions to her abilities I'm really
curious to see where else they go with
it and then a quick cameo by Edna mode
her a previous custom suit for Jack Jack
had just covered the basics because you
know they didn't really know what his
powers work but now it appears Bob is
trying to widen that coverage that
includes this baby monitor tablet device
that tracks when combustion is eminent
well let's move on to this last section
the screen slider interrupts this
program for an important amount up it
might get weird I'll be there okay here
we meet the villain this screen slaver
who uses hypnotism and subliminal
messages for mind control
notice how last a girl is covering her
eyes preventing that from affecting her
mind
now using mass communication for
brainwash you might seem a bit cliche to
us now but remember the incredibles is
set in the a sixties era when the effect
of TV propaganda and advertising on our
minds first began to be criticized and
worried about which obviously was just a
lot of fuss over nothing
look more shapes now the identity of the
screensaver is a mystery to me his voice
actually sounds a lot like James Spader
though maybe my ears are just mixing
them up with Ultron now if you look
closely the shape of his head though it
does appear to match up with Winston
Devers just saying or maybe since we
haven't seen emmalin yet this could be a
big fake-out with the sister behind the
mask
sounds like an evil int eater to me this
final bit with Frozone and his wife is a
callback to one of my favorite jokes of
the first movie
[Music]
comment down below with your favorite
part of this trailer or tweet me
directly at a vas and follow new
rockstars on Twitter for updates on our
videos like it share this video
subscribe to new rockstars for lots of
great videos about Pixar movies we did a
deep rake down of cocoa and the Cars
universe that you should definitely
check out as well as first looks at the
Incredibles teaser that came out a
couple months back and teaser for
wreck-it Ralph - thank you for watching
guys bye
[Music]